mais d'abord donc les relocalisations
c'est aussi un thème de campagne on
détaille les propositions des candidats
avec flora sauvage c'est une priorité
des candidats à la présidentielle quel
que soit leur bord politique
la relocalisation en france et la
réindustrialisation sont au coeur des
programmes si marine le pen privilégie
le patriotisme économique pour localiser
les entreprises françaises eric zemmour
comme valérie pécresse veulent réduire
les impôts et les cotisations des
entreprises
d'abord définir quels sont les
productions stratégie
doit produire chez nous servat de
l'alimentaire
puisque
c'est l'énergie pour arnaud montebourg
chantre du made in france l'état doit
financer la construction d'une usine
dans des filières stratégiques et créé
un délit de trahison économique pour les
dirigeants notre industrie automobile a
relocalisé de l'activité c'est le cas de
renault sur le sol français s'est donc
il est possible de produire en france à
des prix tout à fait compétitif et
raisonnable pour favoriser le retour des
entreprises en france emmanuel macron a
annoncé un plan de relance de 100
milliards d'euros dont 15 milliards pour
l'innovation et des relocalisations un
plan jugé utile par les économistes le
levier importants qui peuvent être
actionnés c'est le en réseau des pme et
on voit bien que récemment ce sont les
pme qui ont bénéficié de ces plans de
relance et l'accent est à mettre sur
ccc entreprises à gauche de la france un
soumise au parti socialiste les
candidats privilégie le renforcement du
rôle de l'état tout en imposant des
normes sociales et environnementales
l'écologiste yannick jadot prévoit lui
de réindustrialiser le pays via la
commande publique
des relocalisations un chiffre record
vous le disais depuis 2009 on en débat
derrière cette bonne nouvelle est ce que
c'est forcément le combat politique et
économique qu'il faut mener aujourd'hui
en france je vous présente mes invités
frédéric coirier bonsoir bien soir vous
êtes chef d'entreprise co président du
mouvement des entreprises de taille
intermédiaire les jeter jean marc daniel
vont soirée quand ce faste professeur
émérite à le slip et business school
mathieu plane économiste à l'ofce un bon
soir l'observatoire français des
conjonctures économiques avec nous en
visioconférence anaïs veille gillies qui
est docteur en géographie et spécialisés
à l'industrie chercheuse associée à
l'université de haute-alsace bonsoir à
vous aussi et les petits circulent pas
et en galice politique à mes côtés bon
bah c'est tout simplement la une de nos
confrères
les échos qui nous a mis sur la piste de
ce débat ce matin avec ce titre la
france marque des points on va détailler
ce qui peut changer en termes d'emploi
d'impact environnemental de souveraineté
je suis un premier tour de table rapide
pour commencer pour voir un peu comment
vous vous situez est-ce que c'est
d'abord une bonne nouvelle frédéric
coirier c'est une bonne nouvelle mais
c'est un petit chiffre en termes
d'emploi 1,2300 les oatei à elle seule
en encre et 26000 sur la même période
alors qu'elles n'ont pas relocalisé
massivement leurs productions nous
pensons que c'est important mais il faut
d'abord travailler la compétitivité
française c'est là qu'on va se jouer le
jeu pour accélérer la
réindustrialisation du pays qui est
nécessaire parce que la structure
économique française est insuffisamment
industrielle par rapport à la proue à
ses principaux voisins et c'est
probablement aussi une des explications
de notre d'écart de chômage avec
l'allemagne avec la hollande et c'est
donc là effectivement c'est une bonne
nouvelle mais c'est loin d'être
suffisant pour vraiment parler de
réindustrialisation du pays petit génie
en présentant les entreprises de taille
intermédiaire on rappelle ce que c'est
alors des entreprises qui font 250 à
5000 salariés c'est à peu près 25 % de
l'emploi salarié en france un tiers des
exportations et on estime à 50 % de
l'industrie française donc la
réindustrialisation passera par le
développement de ces entreprises
évidemment jean marc daniel est ce que
c'est le combat prioritaire pour vous
aujourd'hui
non pas du tout je fais partie des gens
qui pense pas que ce soit une bonne
nouvelle parce que de même qu'il ya 150
ans il y avait des gens qui voulaient
préserver l'agriculture protéger
l'agriculture recréer des emplois dans
l'agriculture je pense que les gens qui
pensent que l'avenir c'est d'euros
localiser des industries qui sont partis
c'est une erreur je pense que le
président de la république quand il a
fait campagne à 5 ans par les deux
start-up nation je pense que c'est là
qu'est l'avenir mois dans l'année les
nouvelles qu'il y avait dans les échos
de ce matin outre seille vélo si le fait
que le prix nobel de physique qui est
italien a expliqué pourquoi on ne
pouvait pas faire de la recherche en
europe et pourquoi il fallait partir aux
états unis et je pense que l'enjeu c'est
plutôt d'avoir des chercheurs plutôt que
des mineurs de fond la grande bretagne
qui a un siècle avait un million deux
cent mille mineurs n'a plus aucun mineur
donc est-ce qu'elle va relocaliser
réouvrir ses mines la réponse est non la
grande bretagne est devenue le premier
pays exportateur d'intelligence donc je
pense que l'avenir c'est plutôt dans ces
secteurs là plutôt que de courir après
le mythe de la réindustrialisation
mathieu plane votre avis non mais bien
sûr je pense c'est une bonne nouvelle
après s'être et microéconomiques 1 on
voit les chiffres effectivement quand on
compare aux grandeurs macroéconomiques
on est sur des toutes petites masses on
voit qu'on est quand même dans une
courbe de désindustrialisation quand
même assez continue depuis 40 ans voit
peut-être un début de mouvement mais qui
aussi mondiale sur ses chaînes de
production qui sont éclatés qu'il faut
aussi des difficultés on voit la clé les
questions d'approvisionnement
donc c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
après c'est effectivement quels sont les
secteurs stratégiques d'avenir sur
quelles filières en réindustraliser
comment on fait voilà après la france a
fait aussi des efforts du côté de sa
compétitivité depuis une dizaine
d'années on voit avec que ce soit le
pack de responsabilité c'est ici les
baisses d'impôt sur la production en
liesse on gagne en attractivité ça
explique aussi explique pourquoi on peut
penser mais on voit bien que à reverser
les mouvements c'est compliqué il ya à
la fois savoir ce qu'ils réindustraliser
qu'est-ce qui est aussi de la capacité
de résilience des pays des chocs
économiques et on le voit sur les
produits qui sont fondamentaux enfin
prenez conomique stratégie dont
souveraineté a pris à la question de
l'art industrie sion plus globale du
véhicule à peu près 80% en r&d en france
quand même l'industrie donc c'est pas
que les mineurs de fond et quand même
des chercheurs dedans
et donc c'est des questions qui sont
essentiels et mon avis la question
fondamentale c'est en fait derrière
c'est qu'elles sont les quelle est la
politique économique à mettre en place
qui est quand même compliquée mais a dit
qu'il faut discuter toyer on parlera
notamment de ce plan france relance
anaïs veut y glisse ce chiffre là c'est
on est à 84 alors ça peut-être évoluer
mais relocalisation depuis le début de
l'année c'était 10 à 20 par an dans la
décennie précédente est ce que vous vous
êtes peut-être je sais pas surprise par
ce chiffre mais surtout est ce qu'il ya
un aspect conjoncturel c'est à dire
c'est lié au contexte que vides cette
prise de conscience que sur certaines
matières premières sur certaines denrées
sur certaines pièces détachées on était
dépendant de d'industrie souvent à
l'autre bout de la planète est ce qu'il
ya un aspect conjoncturel ou est-ce que
vous voyez un mouvement plus
structurelle
une vaste question je pense qu'il ya à
la fois très conjoncturel le plan de
relance qui a mis beaucoup d'argent
public sur la table un plan de relance
présenté par le gouvernement français
mais aussi tous les dispositifs mis aux
échelons régionaux en place qui font
qu'il ya peut-être un phénomène d'effet
d'aubaine derrière c'est 84e
localisation après il va falloir
regarder dans le détail ce que sont ses
projets parce que quand on dit re
localisation en fait on entretient une
sorte de mythe c'est à dire qu'on dit on
va peut-être faire revenir des vieilles
usines dix mille salariés comme on en
avait dans les années 70 et 80 et les
relocalisations c'est pas forcément ça
je me donner un exemple très simple une
entreprise qui s'appelle qui s'appelle
lui ligne elle fait des boîtes à issoire
pour enfants vous allez me dire c'est
pas stratégique etc ils ont commencé
leur première production en chine avec
le parti pris de dire un jour viendra
produire en france et ils ont réussi
leur localisation au pensant totalement
leurs produits et aujourd'hui et
produisent en france presque au même
coût de production qu'en chine donc ça
montre que déjà la relocalisation ça
veut pas forcément dire qu'on va
exploser les coûts après sur ce qui a
été dit mais je pense qu'il ya des
remarques qui mérite d'être fait il faut
jamais un critique et des
relocalisations quelle qu'elle soit
c'est mieux quand elles se font par la
volonté des entreprises et en dehors
d'un support massif dette publique sans
ça qu'il faut bien mettre prendre des
pincettes qui se passe mais l'enjeu
c'est quand même de créer de la valeur
sur notre territoire
bien quand on a des industrialisés on a
aussi vendu le mythe d'une société post
industrielle qui allez pouvoir créer
suffisamment de valeur sur les tâches en
amont et en aval des activités de
production sauf que ce qu'on constate
c'est que la france n'a pas réussi ce
pari est qu'aujourd'hui les pays qui
sont en train de venir les grandes
puissances mondiales sont aussi des pays
qui misent sur leur industrie qui
comprennent qu'il ya un intérêt à avoir
un lien entre usines et innovation parce
qu'en fait l'innovation
aujourd'hui c'est principalement tirée
par des industriels est ce donc ce lien
il est assez important est la dernière
chose c'est que les leaders
d'aujourd'hui ils sont en sus leader
dans des secteurs industriels et que on
se désindustrialise ans on perd notre
culture industrielle on perd la
compréhension de ce que sont les
produits puisque ce sont les matières et
donc se dire on va continuer à innover
continue à faire de la recherche mais si
on a pas d'application produit alors je
pense qu'on se trompe un peu de combat
ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'il faut
toujours localisées qui voit là il faut
vraiment poser le débat sereinement et
se dire qu'est ce qu'on met derrière le
mot rien du str égalisation et sortir un
peu de certains stéréotypes comme on a
tendance à le faire on reviendra vers
vous évidemment tout à l'heure on va
donc se questionner notamment autour de
la politique du gouvernement et du
président de la république
emmanuel macron je pense que si le
jourdain doit être juste derrière
tu peux me rejoindre toutefois steve
c'était une priorité pour le prénom
république à la sortie du premier
confinement si on fait le bilan un an et
demi après quel résultat attention
accrochez-vous je vais vous donner plein
de chiffres dommage vous laisse ce soin
ensuite de les faire parler les premiers
chiffres dont on dispose date de
septembre 2000 20 septembre 2020
rappelez vous c'est le moment le
gouvernement décide et bien de lancer
son grand plan de relance 100 milliards
d'euros pour créer de nouveaux emplois
et redresser l'économie française une
économie qui subit alors de plein fouet
la crise sanitaire parmi les priorités
du gouvernement la relocalisation
d'industrie dites stratégiques et la
création d'emplois selon les chiffres du
gouvernement depuis septembre 2020 624
projet de relocalisation et est soutenu
par l'état toujours selon le
gouvernement ces relocalisations aurait
permis de créer ou de préserver
77 mille emplois industriels plusieurs
grands secteurs sont concernés santé
agroalimentaire ou encore electronic
alors si on fait le bilan relocalisation
délocalisation depuis mars 2020 c'est on
a pris cette date de départ ça donne
quoi alors la société trendeo a fait un
état des lieux le bilan on va le voir
depuis septembre 2020 115 sociétés vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure thomas 115
sociétés ont rapatrié des activités dans
l'hexagone sur l'année 2021 le bilan est
plutôt bon puisque pour la deuxième
année consécutive les relocalisations
étaient plus nombreuses que les
délocalisations
mais si on se penche de plus près sur
ces chiffres on s'aperçoit qui bien que
ce sont surtout les pme qui en
profitaient vous le disais tout à
l'heure qui ont engagé des
relocalisations ce qui veut dire qu'en
matière de création d'emplois
industriels on n'aboutit pas à des
chiffres incroyables thomas regarder
toujours selon trendeo depuis
2009 moins de 9000 emplois ont été
rapatriés en france ça correspond à
seulement
0,5 pour cent de l'emploi créé en france
sur la période dit autrement les 84
activités de retour en france en 2021 ne
feront travailler que 2300 salariés
c'est bien c'est important le
gouvernement s'en félicite mais la
bataille pour la bat pour la pour
l'emploi industriel est encore très loin
d'être gagné merci steve forcés pour ces
chiffres ici et ses explications
effectivement frédéric poirier la part
des entreprises de taille intermédiaire
dans cette rue colocalisation est-ce que
c'est d'abord des entreprises de cette
taille là qu'ils peuvent le faire
lorsqu'on parle aussi me qui peut qui
peut s'engager dans un mouvement parfait
tel recueil relocalise pas elles sont
elles s'étaient déjà là et elles
grandissent d'accord moi je suis un
exemple j'ai créé une centaine d'emplois
cette année j'ai investi geparo
localiser votre entreprise c'est les
cheminées poujoulat j'ai investi j'ai
innové j'ai créé des nouveaux produits
vous auriez pu partir on s'est pas posé
sincèrement la question on suit nos
clients sur certains marchés donc on a
des usines en pologne au danemark là où
on vend mais quand on peut faire en
france ont fait en france où savez quand
on compare aujourd'hui l'investissement
en france et en allemagne c'est frappant
les entreprises allemandes investissent
deux fois plus chez elle que les
entreprises françaises en france
pourquoi parce que l'écosystème de
compétitivité n'est pas le n'est pas
comparable en france on a des impôts de
production qui ont commencé à baisser
dans le cadre du plan de relance on a
travaillé sur les charges mais plutôt
sur les bas salaires mais la france
n'est pas une économie des bas salaires
la france n'est pas un pays low cost on
est plutôt un pays à salaires élevés
donc il faut travailler la compétitivité
pour pouvoir dégager des marges de
manoeuvre investir innover exporté en
fait il faut comme jean marc daniel il
faut pas penser qu'on va rapatrier des
actifs à basse valeur ajoutée ça ne
marchera pas il faut surtout monter en
gamme monte en qualité mais pour sa
démarche de m'annoncer 2 de l'argent mis
par l'état sur cet enjeu de relocaliser
alors quand c'est la mémétique la
communication comme illégales dans leur
relance si elle commet une grosse farce
et le fonds de solidarité sé on a
préservé des activités vrai argent qui
était mis sur la table pour investir
c'est la baisse des impôts de production
10 milliards qui ont été sur des deux
années c'est effectivement
l'accompagnement par voie de subventions
de projets d'investissement c'est bien
mais mais c'est one shot c'est une fois
la baisse et fin la subvention il faut
pas que ça devienne la règle nous on
n'est pas demandeur de ça on demande
plutôt d'aligner la france sur la
moyenne européenne sur les impôts de
production les dix premiers milliards
c'est déjà un pas très important
personne n'avait fait avant la moyenne
européenne s'est encore 35 milliards de
moins oui on a fait un bout de chemin
mais on n'est qu'à un tiers du chemin à
faire sur les charges on a baissé les
charges des bas salaires mais tous les
gens qui aujourd'hui font l'innovation
fonds de commerce le développement le le
digital sont des salaires élevés et or
les salaires en france fin sur ses
salaires là les charges sont deux fois
plus élevés que la moyenne européenne
tant qu'on n'aura pas réaligner tous ces
agrégats économiques sur nos voisins on
ne pourra pas faire la mutation de masse
et je pense que la réindustrialisation
qu'on appelle tous de nos voeux ne se
fera qu'à partir du moment où on recrée
les conditions
moyennes en tout cas européenne je ne
parle même pas de l'allemagne qui est
encore beaucoup moins élevé en termes de
coûts de production il ya la dimension
politique qui nous intéresse aussi dans
ce débat laetitia parce que ce thème des
relocalisations
il est clairement porter dans cette dans
cette campagne vous êtes allé chercher
la com autour de la souveraineté
économique avec le made in france et oui
le médecin c'est devenu un slogan on en
a l'habitude parce qu'à chaque campagne
à ce salon à paris où les candidats
défilent et puis joue un petit peu c'est
un peu comme de son agriculture
finalement à qui aura le plus de médias
qui restera le plus longtemps dans les
allées et qui finalement aura un peu le
totem du made in france voilà donc c'est
vrai que c'est très consensuel
finalement comme sujet je me suis amusé
à compiler des petits moments avec cette
année le passage de plusieurs candidats
regardez
moi je je m'amuse beaucoup de voir la
gaule o mania qui les prend tous ils ont
tous oublié tout à mettre tant mieux
bien sûr qu'il ya une imposture de
certains bien sûr comme emmanuel macron
qui va inaugurer des usines de masse que
je le disais tout à l'heure et qui
achète tous les masques au vietnam
l'état achète les masques vietnam en
chine c'est insupportable
ça fait plus longtemps que ça
me dire que dans la classe politique
bon alors marine le pen sur sept ce
sujet la raison un c'est vrai qu'en 2012
elle était déjà là avec un béret sur la
tête voilà pour défendre toujours un peu
la même idée alors à change le de mots
mais c'est toujours cette même idée de
protectionnisme à la française et c'est
vrai que nicolas dupont aignan soulève
quand même une question qui a fait
polémique au début de la pandémie et qui
reste à mon avis qui n'est pas soldé
cette question effectivement de la
souveraineté de la production de masques
pourquoi elle reste dans l'esprit des
français parce que on l'a tous vécu donc
c'est très concret c'est direct et les
français n'ont toujours pas confiance
dans le gouvernement pour les protéger
puisque on a vu qu effectivement ces
images sur les tarmacs où on allait
chercher directement les masques à la
descente d avion c'était catastrophique
1 vraiment pour la confiance qu un
peuple peut avoir dans son gouvernement
et c'est vrai que quand on regarde les
candidats ont défilé évidemment de
montebourg lui il a carrément son rond
de serviette ans est lui un peu le
monsieur à médine france c'est lui qui a
lancé salon et puis il est aussi là en
tant que producteur français donc il y
là cette petite musique depuis depuis un
moment mais pour en tout cas la campagne
qui nous intéresse c'est un slogan
marketing le made in france parce que
dans le moment pour le moment dans les
propositions les candidats restent
encore très floues même eric zemmour qui
était dans le salon qui en a parlé
pendant son meeting bon c'est toujours
un peu les mêmes clichés dans les
méthodes dont on ne sait pas comment ils
vont faire pour réussir à établir et
installer ce protectionnisme à la
française est alors le plus intéressant
c'était emmanuel macron qu'il n'y était
pas un puisqu'il n'est pas encore
candidat il n'a pas fait le déplacement
au salon mais j'ai retrouvé une
interview de lui quand il était candidat
en 2016 est ce qu'il disait c'est pour
ça que monsieur c'est intéressant ce
votre intervention tout à l'heure parce
qu'ils allaient dans ce sens là il
disait le made in france complet n'est
pas toujours la bonne option quand on
fait tout en france on n'est pas
forcément gagnant cela dépend du paysage
compétitif c'était quand même à ce
moment là un positionnement qui était
originale parce que tout le monde dans
ce cliché du made in france de la france
qui n'a besoin de personne pour être
forte et souveraine et emmanuel macron
faisait jouer notre musique est-ce qu'il
a changé puisque en lançant france 2030
il met 34 milliards sur la table et il
saute on l'a tous remarqué l'élection
présidentielle puisqu'il est déjà lui
projeté en 2030 donc ce serait
intéressant dans la campagne évidemment
de lui poser la question sur sa volonté
politique jean marc daniel 7 cet argent
parce que j'ai bien compris que vous
disiez ça doit pas être un totem la
relocalisation là on l'a bien compris
mais on peut quand même utiliser
l'argent public l'argent de ce plan
france reprend se lance pour relocaliser
certaines activités bien choisi non je
pense pas je pense qu'on l'a dit c'est
les chefs d'entreprises qui créent la
richesse les entreprises qui
investissent et donc si on doit les
aider il ya qu'à baisser leurs impôts on
vient de le dire la façon la plus simple
qu'à chaque fois que l'état se mêle de
vouloir et identifie suis étiez
stratégiques ou pas ça se termine plus
ou moins par un fiasco je vais pas
revenir jusqu'au plan calcul de de
gaulle au minitel dont se vantait d'être
à la pointe du progrès et mitterrand
avait conclu en disant oui c'est bien
minitel tout le monde nous l'envient
mais personne ne nous lâche est alors je
pense qu'effectivement l'état n'est pas
le bon outil en revanche qu'on baisse
les impôts si l'état en outre investi
considérablement dans l'éducation et
dans la formation c'est pour générer des
emplois de haut niveau et doit de valeur
ajoutée à quoi ça sert de dire qu'il
faut faire un effort de formation si à
la fin on vous dit mais rassurez vous on
va rapatrier simultanément les ouvriers
les emplois du textile chinois qui sont
de qualité assez médiocre et qui demande
donc une formation puisqu'ils sont
occupés par des chinois qui sortent
juste la campagne qui sont le fruit de
l'exode rural dont il ya une
contradiction dans tout ça et je pense
que l'effectif ans emmanuel macron 2016
si une campagne la fois courageuse et
cohérente autour de la notion de start
up nation en disant bien que c'est les
chefs d'entreprise qui serait la clé du
système que le rôle de l'état n'était
pas de freiner effectivement la
dynamique d'entrepreneuriat et surtout
que le protectionnisme était un
véritable danger le protectionnisme je
rappelle la formule de james tobin au
moment où il y avait des gens qui se
réclament et de lui pour faire une taxe
sur les mouvements de capitaux et ça et
qui se définissait comme étant
ouvertement protectionnistes lisez
écoutez moi je suis économiste et
économistes sont par nature contre le
protectionnisme à part quelques-uns
disait-il mais ils sont par nature
contre le protectionnisme et dans ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'effectivement
la réflexion économique ça fait deux
siècles que les économistes mettent en
avant que le protectionnisme c'est une
ponction sur le pouvoir d'achat c'est
une inefficacité économique garantie
c'est du gaspillage d'argent public ça
fait deux siècles dit ça est en face
d'une opinion publique soutenu par ses
dirigeants qui est persuadé que le
protectionnisme c'est la solution est
donc le véritable enjeu pour les hommes
politiques c'est de passer de la phase
pédagogique on va vous expliquer
pourquoi on n'est pas protectionniste
maquereau en 2016 de rester dans cette
phase là et pas de sombrer dans la phase
démagogie comme ça vous allez voir ce
que vous allez voir le made in france
profonde conclure encore une fois valéry
giscard d'estaing aussi au moment du
choc pétrolier quand ils ont lancé la
chasse au gaspi disais bien écouté du
pétrole on an'a pas et donc on en
trouvera pas on ne pourra pas se
substituer au pétrole on m'a fabriquera
pas donc il faudra bien qu'on importe
donc on n'a pas de pétrole on aura des
idées et je pense que le véritable enjeu
c'est pas d'avoir de l'industrie et de
faire des masques c'est d'avoir des
idées mais
il ya quand même une demande des
consommateurs aussi qu'on peut pas
sous-estimer demande de de production
locale de relocalisation de pouvoir
d'achat oui aussi pouvoir d'achat
effectivement si c'est si c'est dû mais
une france beaucoup plus cher que
ça c'est aussi c'est quand même un défi
les entreprises veulent répondant bien
sûr il ya un déclin qui pousse huawei ce
que je veux dire qu'il ya plusieurs
enjeux autour de ça et effectivement la
question du pouvoir d'achat donc la
compétitivité qui se pose de la valeur
ajoutée produite ou si donc
effectivement on imagine bien qu'on va
pas produire les textiles comme on le
faisait avant donc si on fait du textile
ça va être du textile au niveau des
marques qui sont plutôt des marques de
luxe
il ya ça mais il ya aussi d'autres
enjeux c'est à dire que les autres pays
n'appliquent pas des règles de libre
échange gentiment en quoi c'est à dire
qu'il ya un interventionnisme qui est
fort il ya la question écologique la
gestion de la transition écologique et
rapprocher le producteur du consommateur
peut penser être quand même un peu du
bon sens dans certains cas et puis on
voit bien dans l'optimisation des
chaînes de production mondiale il ya
aussi des difficultés aujourd'hui dans
cet éclatement des chaînes de production
donc y compris quand on considère que
c'est l'entreprise qui doit choisir
rationnellement on revoit des mouvements
en fait plutôt continentaux alors ça
sera pas du made in france mais
s'appelle du made in europe si l'accès
des questions qui vont se poser est
aujourd'hui un des enjeux c'est le dire
est ce qu'il faut pas mettre une taxe
carbone aux frontières européennes pour
favoriser des productions qui sont
plutôt décarbonés et donc forcément vous
faites une forme de protectionnisme et
qui a une protectionnisme intelligent
pareil sur les droits sociaux on peut se
poser la question c'est à dire qu est-ce
qu est-ce qu on se considère comme
équitable dans la façon de produire
c'est à dire 'est-ce qu'on applique les
mêmes réseaux sociaux c'est quoi sur la
fiscalité aussi on voit l'enjeu sur les
gars femmes et l'optimisation fiscale
qui peut être fait donc ça soulève
toutes ces questions là j'ai pas une
solution extrême les candidats à la
présidentielle non selon vous est-ce
qu'ils ont un programme qui est assez
élaboré sur la question le programme va
dire qu'on entend beaucoup c'est de
baisser la fiscalité et qu'il ya quand
même des effets effectivement les impôts
sur la production ont touché plus tôt
l'industrie il ya un débat qui est assez
fort qui est sûre la commande publique
qui représente beaucoup il ya ce small
business act aux etats-unis 1 qui
privilégie les pme aux états unis voilà
c'est des questions qui sont fortes mais
c'est aussi à traiter au niveau européen
parce que vous avez quand même toute la
question du l'europe s'est construit sur
libre échange et éviter les ce qu'on
appelle les distorsions de concurrence à
partir quand vous faites des choses qui
sont des aides spécifiques à certains
secteurs où vous créer des distorsions
de concurrence donc ça veut dire c'est
pas que le schéma franco-français sur
lesquels il faut raisonner mais c'est le
schéma robin et quand vous parlez de
textes carbone aux frontières nationales
parler des frontières européennes ou
parlez pas de frontière française anaïs
utilise effectivement c'est à ce niveau
européen qu'il faut il faut traiter
cette question pour vous
il ya une logique à envisager bien
entendu des réponses à l'échelle
européenne puisque on a une taille de
marché aussi qui est plus pertinente
maintenant ce dont on se rend compte
aussi c'est la difficulté que les 27
états membres on a parlé d'une voix
commune puisqu'ils ont des intérêts
stratégiques qui sont très très
différents par exemple l'allemagne qui
est un pays qui exporte beaucoup exporte
beaucoup vers la chine ce qui peut bien
lui poser des questions de mettre
certaines mesures aux frontières
européennes puisque ça pourrait ne plus
profiter à son industrie et on peut
donner des exemples très simple pour
illustrer sa il ya eu un débat sur la
réciprocité d'accès aux marchés publics
c'est à dire de dire que pour qu'une
entreprise d'un pays en dehors de
l'union européenne puissent accéder aux
marchés publics européens il faut que le
pays dont elle est originaire ouvre
aussi largement son marché public aux
entreprises européennes et il ya eu un
refus des états du nord de l'europe de
mettre en place cette mesure de
réciprocité dans l'accès aux marchés
publics européens en raison d'intérêts
divergents on a eu des débats aussi sur
la question de contrôle des
investissements étrangers où on a
atterri à un accord a minima qui repose
sur des échanges d'information
l'échelon européen pour plein de choses
et aussi pourtant c'est sûrement une
politique industrielle européenne qui
n'est aujourd'hui pas une compétence de
la compétence exclusive de l'échelon
européen mérite d'être posée on a aussi
beaucoup de sujets qui ont été
aussi sous entendus à l'intérieur de
l'europe en termes de dumping c'est très
difficile d'adopter une position commune
quand vous avez des états ou
le coût du travail horaire est de 9
euros quand il est de 38 euros en france
quand vous avez un dumping fiscal très
fort entre les différents états c'est un
peu la course avec qui exporte 60
chômage soit importe et sièges
d'entreprises chez lui et donc c'est si
un échelon psig laisse à penser
qu'aujourd'hui il faut aussi trouver des
solutions nationales qui ne soit pas le
protectionnisme parce que ce n'est pas
forcément une réponse mais il faut pas
non plus être les naïfs de la
mondialisation c'est-à-dire quand des
pays sont capables de fermer leurs
frontières sur certains secteurs parce
qu'ils ont décidé de créer des leaders
nationaux nous devons aussi être capable
de doter de réponse par ailleurs une
dernière chose on parle de déficit de
compétitivité sur la fiscalité mais
quand on oblige les industriels à
investir énormément sur le plan
environnemental pour offrir des produits
de qualité etc ça crée un déficit de
compétitivité donc il est normal et bien
de remettre quelque chose d'un mécanisme
qui peut être la taxe carbone aux
frontières européennes ou des taxe
kilométrique etc pour équilibrer ce jeu
n'est pas normal qu'on demande à aux
industriels français d'être vertueux et
qu'on laisse entrer sur le territoire
français des produits qui peuvent être
produits dans des conditions sociales ou
environnementales totalement
catastrophique à une heure ou une heure
où tout le monde parle de réchauffement
climatique laëtitia ou les intervenants
oui bah justement juste pour illustrer
ce que vous venez de dire c'est vrai qu
emmanuel macron quand il présente france
2030 c'est exactement l'argumentaire du
chef de l'état c'est à dire qu'il dit
que ça va permettre de décarbonés par
exemple hydrogène l'économie et lui
parie sur la localisation de nouvelles
technologies d'avenir donc ce n'est pas
comme vous le disiez monsieur la
relocalisation d'un d'entreprise
d'industrie du 19e siècle enfin essayer
de faire revenir les gens non c'est pas
ça c'est on est déjà à l'étape d'après
et on crée des génie français des
leaders français dans les technologies
de l'avenir comme l'hydrogène alors
justement va écouter le prénom
république qui faisait un peu le service
après vente de son de son plan ils
étaient 25 octobre par exemple à
saint-etienne en écoute emmanuel macron
le train dustrit sera de plus en plus
moderne elle aura de plus en plus deux
composantes d'intelligence artificielle
de plus en plus d'innovation elle est à
la croisée de laboratoires de recherche
publics privés de grands groupes et donc
c'est aussi pour ça que voilà cette
famille de robotisation modernisation et
elle sera au coeur de ce projet france
2030 on pourra ré industrialiser la
france grâce aux transformations
auxquelles vous contribuez on va pas
réindustrialiser la france en
redéveloppant l'industrie qu'on
connaissait il ya 20 ans ou 30 ans la
nostalgie n'est pas bonne conseillère la
nostalgie n'est pas bonne conseillère
qu'auriez vous êtes d'accord avec cette
idée là ils annoncent plutôt de des
milliards pour effectivement créer de
nouvelles filières et à finir de
l'hydrogène verts il ya la question du
spatial du new space avec les satellites
il ya la question aussi
du nucléaire évidemment avec les mini
réacteurs et semi conducteurs ça aussi
on m'a souvent été là dessus
vous approuver cette décision là où en
tout cas cette ambition là mais en tout
cas la france peut se réindustrialiser
sur la qualité elle le doit enfin sur
incertaine une certaine montée en gamme
on a une chance extraordinaire en france
c'est con on a aujourd'hui capacité à
produire décarbonés dès aujourd'hui par
rapport à l'europe les parties fines à
l'électricité nucléaire le kilowattheure
aujourd'hui en france c'est 70 grammes
de co2 en allemagne ces trois à quatre
cent en chine ces mille donc produire en
france ces produits déjà écologique donc
c'est une chance extraordinaire que nous
avons de pouvoir disposer de ce moyen
sachant que les allemands vont avoir un
mal fou ça va leur coûter un argent fou
ça va prendre beaucoup de temps pour
arriver à notre niveau donc ça c'est une
vraie chance pour nous le fait de deux
de gagner en compétitivité peut
permettre et c'est effectivement aux
entreprises de se rebaptiser de se
transformer d'innover c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure il faut rentrer
dans une dans une accélération de ces
transformations on ne fera pas de
l'industrie bas niveau en france on le
sait tous par contre il faut transformer
plus en france un emploi industriel
c'est deux à trois emplois induits
innover innover est ce que transformer
série a mais en plus la valeur la valeur
ajoutée quand vous êtes juste négociant
vous apporte un container sait pas grand
chose en france 1 quand vous produisez
en france vous avez trois fois plus de
valeur si on veut que le pays s'enrichit
il faut qu'elles s'enrichissent par
l'ape transformation la production
valeur ajoutée bien entendu
compétitivité pour être attractif parce
que si vous êtes beaucoup plus cher que
la l'importation le consommateur ira
naturellement vers l'implantation donc
ça on est tous d'accord mais il faut
transformer plus sur notre territoire
est effectivement tout ça ça implique
énormément d'efforts sur les années qui
viennent décarbonation sa
désinvestissement est gigantesque
on les dit pas vraiment aujourd'hui mais
c'est des centaines de milliards des
milliers de milliards qui va falloir
faire dans un temps extrêmement court
les entreprises si elles n'ont pas de
marge de manoeuvre ne pourront pas le
faire donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut
faire les mesures de compétitivité
continuer à innover pour être
effectivement proposant de service de
produits a pas que les produits les
services de qualité qui vont aussi
porter des réponses aux consommateurs et
emmené l'ensemble de nos entreprises
vers une montée en gamme mais pas en
disant on va faire du luxe tout
simplement en innovant en améliorant et
en se modernisant en cela le président
tout à fait raison mais pour faire ces
transformations il faut baisser la ligne
de flottaison des entreprises sens elles
n'auront pas les marges nécessaires pour
le faire alors on va prendre un exemple
tout de suite avec une entreprise de
surgelés de poisson qui est dans le gers
à fleurance avec nous stéphanie pistre
qui est en visioconférence et qui est la
présidente de gimbert surgelés bonsoir
vous étiez présent en chine vous avez
décidé de créer une usine dans le gers
pourquoi vous investissez en français
expliquez nous
il faut savoir que effectivement nous
produisions des produits surgelés de la
mer
mais par contre on n'en avions pas d'une
machine on était obligé de passer par la
chine parce que la chine et l'ue digne
du mam et que le marché de travail du
poisson sur les est obligé de passer par
la china alors effectivement
quand la croissance pour notre
entreprise était là peut se dire que par
facilité et puis part parce qu'on
n'avait pas le choix la transformation
se fait en chine
on a pris la décision effectivement
de localiser que pour nous ce n'est pas
une relocalisation ce n'est pas une
réindustrialisation
il faut savoir que l'industrie qu'on va
créer de la façon dont on va la craie
n'existe pas ni en transe voire même pas
en europe et un monopole d'une industrie
manufacturière qui étaient faites en
chine parce que l'organisation mondiale
du travail du passant charlie était un
chien donc la crise sanitaire
plus effectivement l'explosion du fret
maritime nous conforte dans notre
décision
d'implanter cette étude pour du champ
chez nous
et le plan de relance pour lequel nous
avons été aidés n'a pas été un
déclencheur du projet
mais pour nous est également un signal
envoyé par le gouvernement à nous dire
qu on est dans la bonne direction et
qu'on n'est pas les seuls à croire à ce
projet qui paraît un peu fou il ya
plusieurs éléments qui sont qui sont
passionnants d'abord je rebondis sur ce
raid est effectivement vous l'auriez
fait sens
alors d'accord vous l'auriez fait de
deuxième aspect comment vous vous créez
donc cette usine avec je l'imaginé une
robotisation importante
alors il faut savoir effectivement voilà
que l'industrie et glee pandas en chine
le paradoxe n'est que la chine pourrait
avoir les moyennes automatisé cette
production à mai elle est totalement
manufacturés rona on a face à nous des
industries
massive avec 1 200 300 milles 1 mille
salariés ouvriers chinois qui filait à
la bête pour pouvoir l'implanter
empreinte évidemment on va pas créer 500
1000 2000 emplois français donc pour
être compétitif dans ce marché là on va
être dans une automatisation la plus
culte et à son extrême
avec bien évidemment des humains autour
des machines
qui va être des humains des dans la
production des techniciens de
maintenance
alors nous on va créer entre 20 voire
même 50 emplois si notre projet et
explose de commandes comment le pas en
fumée au delà de notre entreprise c'est
un tissu économique local voir prince et
il va étoffer se construire autour de
notre projet
dernière question sur l'aspect
environnemental
ils vont faire quoi beaucoup de beaucoup
moins de kilomètres pardon d'être aussi
basique mais ses surgelés de poisson ça
va changer quoi
dis donc effectivement on supprimerait
et en supprimera la tribune air est
devient la chine c'est à dire qu'aucun
importants sont pêchés dans leurs zones
d'origine
dans l'alaska quittons donc prochain des
eaux territoriales des états unis de
russie
elle transite elles sont envoyés en
chine pour être transformée gilles été
décongelé puis congelé pour repartir
dans les marchés américain et européen
non ce qu'on va faire c'est
qu'effectivement on va supprimer cette
étape chinoise et on va s'approvisionner
directement dans les zones de pêche des
partants d'origine merci pour ce
témoignage merci stéphanie pistre je
rappelle que vous êtes un patron de
l'entreprise gimbert surgelés ya il ya
plusieurs aspects je reviens sur la
robotisation mathieu plane
c'est intéressant parce que là on crée
un nouveau business mais il est pas très
créateurs d'emplois non non il ya
créateur de rim création de valeur
ajoutée et donc ça c'est intéressant
mais effectivement il est moins intense
en emploi c'est le pari qui peut être
fait c'est à dire que forcément avec un
coût du travail qui plus est les niveaux
de vie sont plus élevés en france qu'en
chine donc c'est une évidence avec les
salaires sont plus élevés en france il
faut qu'en face il ya des gains de
productivité qu'ils soient plus élevés
donc forcément être compétitif ça passe
effectivement par les coûts mais aussi
par l'innovation les gains de
productivité et donc forcément si vous
allez rapatriés ou en tout cas à
relocaliser certaines productions vous
n'avez pas le faire comme nous le
faisait en chine sinon on n'avait pas
d'intérêt à le faire ou alors c'est
parce que les coûts du transport ont
explosé où il ya des barrières
douanières que vous n'aviez pas etc mais
clairement les pays qui sont quand même
aussi on va dire compétitifs sont des
pays qui sont innovants et qui ont des
gains de productivité donc ça passe
aussi par tout un écosystème qui passe
juste la localisation mais ça va
effectivement de l'éducation la
formation la r&d l'accompagnement de
l'innovation effectivement est ce que
par exemple le crédit d'impôt recherche
en france ou 6 1 qui favorise
l'implantation de centres de r&d donc
c'est tout ça c'est tout un écosystème
donc c'est pas dit on va relocaliser
toute la production c'est favoriser
justement l'émergence de certaines
industries ou en tout cas les
accompagner on sait qu'il ya des enjeux
pour le futur qui sont assez connues
mais il ya aussi le fait que voilà si
vous êtes innovants et vous créez vous
avez la productivité ça peut être
intéressant de de produire et y compris
en france même si le coût du travail
plus élevé l'autre aspect c'est l'aspect
environnemental frais et coirier là là
on est dans quand même un impact enfin
une baisse de l'impact qui est réel
termes d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre tout tout simplement je reviens à
ce que je disais tout à l'heure moi je
pense qu'il ya un argument qui est
majeur aujourd'hui c'est quand même
l'argument des consommateurs même si le
prix est certainement le premier ce
qu'est ce qu'on regarde en premier il ya
de plus en plus de consommateurs qui
font des choix lié à l'impact
environnemental des entreprises donc le
circuit court donc la relocalisation
c'est aussi une façon de répondre à
cette demande bien sûr mais les
consommateurs moi je le vois par rapport
à mes produits c'est un argument g 92%
de production
qui est en france
j'entends aussi des amis qui qui
fabrique des meubles en vendée les
meubles gauthier qui quitte aujourd'hui
60% de les consommateurs qui viennent
dans les boutiques demande d'où viennent
les produits donc c'est un argument
c'est pas ça qui va permettre de vendre
50% plus cher mais peut-être 5 %
peut-être 10% il ya quand même un
sentiment qui s'est développée et puis
encore une fois c'est beaucoup de
création de valeur on dit 25 à 30
emplois cette dame de donner mais on dit
pas tout ce qui va y avoir autour il
faudra des gens pour entretenir il
faudra des face à va créer à tout un
écosystème elle avait tout à fait raison
les 25 l'emploi bon sens fort et
peut-être 25 emplois indirects sous 50
emplois indirects des emplois qualifiés
bien formés bien payé puisque
l'industrie paye bien un cc il faut le
dire c'est pas elle ne s'est pas un
secteur de bas salaires contrairement à
beaucoup d'idées reçues donc c'est oui
c'est effectivement positif et puis il
ya un retour sur investissement
économique et écologique c'est les deux
vont de pair ce qui est quand même très
intéressant et vous avez les chiffres
thomas moi je mets un peu en doute ce
que vous avancez parce qu'il me semble
que monsieur vous parler de sentiment et
je pense qu'on est vraiment là dans un
sentiment est pas concrètement dans on
achète plus quel que soit les français
globalement n'achète plus parce que
c'est français c'est pas vrai je pense
que vous nous avez
l'exemple du lait le lait bio a perdu
des parts de marché par rapport au lait
local donc c'est cet argument de la
provenance et de la localisation du
produit
les français compétitif fouette les
doigts et se placer au mieux cela se
gâte ses parts de marché ce qu'ils
perdent des parts de marché sur le lait
c'est d'avoir le lait bio parce que
c'est plus cher ensuite c'est le lait
local mais quand vous regardez les qui
sont sûrs acheter nos nos divers pourri
de leurs communautés européennes sur
ceux qui sont les plus vendus et c'est
historique ça quand le made in est
inventé par les anglais pour stigmatiser
les produits venant d'allemagne en
disant ils sont certes moins cher mais
ils sont fabriqués par notre ennemi
potentiel lors made in germany quand
vous faites ça vous favorisez l'ennemi
ça passait le mont olympe lien au bout
de six mois les produits allemands
avaient explosé parce que les anglais
faire repérer qu'ils étaient moins chers
que les produits anglais et donc le
consommateur la première chose qui le
fait réagir c'est pour ça que la taxe
carbone c'est là le vrai enjeu parce qu
elle la taxe carbone elle fait réagir le
consommateur le même en termes d'emploi
il faut pas se faire d'illusions il ya
deux choses qui vont jouer le premier
c'est que quand general motors à la
demande de train par localiser une usine
qui était au mexique il trompe a demandé
la direction general motors vous allez
créer combien d'emplois ils ont répondu
06 ont leur eau localise c'est pour être
dans un endroit où il y aura que des
robots et quand on leur a demandé
pourquoi voulez le mettre en caroline du
sud et pas des trois puisque c'est zéro
emploi c'est parce qu'en caroline du sud
les impôts sont les moins élevés et donc
l'attitude des entreprises et de payer
le moins d'impôts et du consommateur
c'est de payer moins cher moins cher
possible et la deuxième remarque que je
ferai c'est que la vague de
délocalisations maintenant va toucher le
tertiaire on a fait du télétravail les
gens qui vont à la défense pour
travailler on leur a dit vous pouvez
travailler puis rambouillet ou orléans
mais il ya déjà acquis on va dire
bientôt mais si on peut le faire à
rambouillet orléans on peut le faire à
brazzaville parce qu'on parle français à
brazzaville on a été bien formés on est
capable de faire la même chose que les
gens qui sont à envoyer à orléans donc
la délocalisation et tous nos portes sur
tout un tas d'autres activités donc il
ya un véritable enjeu qui n'est pas
douleur localisée métier de
véritablement formé à haut niveau notre
meilleur match je plains tu n'aurais je
pas alors il ya d'abord identifier ce
que c'est que le made in france aussi
c'est pas toujours facile puisqu'il faut
savoir quel est le contenu en valeur
ajoutée d'un produit et à partir de
quand on considère c'est du made in
france c'est par exemple vers une
origine france forcément la valeur du
produit les enquêtes d'opinion montrent
que les français sont prêts en moyenne à
payer jeu contre 5 et 10 % de plus pour
des produits qui seraient médine france
alors après concrètement est ce que ça
se ferait ou pas fougamou aussi dire que
si la valeur ajoutée est réalisée sur le
territoire c'est aussi des emplois c'est
la masse salariale cés des recettes
fiscales donc il ya quand même un enjeu
économique ya pas qu un coût
supplémentaire il ya aussi voilà
forcément si vous acheter made in france
ou soutenez un emploi qui est domestiqué
locales et donc qui crée de l'activité
dont il ya tous est cet enjeu la global
mais c'est vrai que je pense que malgré
tout ça passe par des incitations
fiscales qui sont importantes et l'enjeu
écologique me semble assez intéressant
là dessus pour éviter que des biens soit
enfin voilà vous avez l'exemple du bois
en france qui va être produit en france
la matière première va être exporté à
l'autre bout du monde et est ramené sous
forme de l'oeuvre on devrait pouvoir le
transformer en problème look à la
question de la transformation et donc si
vous mettez un enjeu écologique en
disant effectivement il ya un contenu
carbone qui est beaucoup plus élevé que
vous allez taxer au créa une incitation
forte par les prix mais parce que vous
le considérez que c'est par la taxation
du carbone ouais sur sur syrte qu'est
cette question anaïs willis de l'enjeu
environnemental l'impact de ces enjeux
sur la consommation est ce qu'il ya un
aspect générationnel pour vous dire est
ce qu'il ya une nouvelle génération qui
est encore plus sensible aux beaucoup
plus sensible que la précédente sur ces
questions et donc avec un impact sur sa
consommation
oui et non en fait oui à toute une
partie des jeunes générations qui est
très sensible à cette question
environnementale est d'ailleurs qu'il
est se seront inscrits à la fois dans
les actes d'achat mais aussi dans la
tente qu'ils ont à l'égard des
entreprises où ils travaillent et puis
il ya aussi des gens qui sont qui sont
moins sensibles mais ce qu'on voit c'est
que globalement la pression est mise
plutôt par les jeunes on voit dans le
cadre contre garde les marches pour le
climat etc c'est d'abord était plutôt
initiée par des jeunes bardés très jeune
et c'est aussi toute cette génération
qui vit avec qui ce qui tu veux dire de
manière peut-être un peu cru mais qui
quand le réchauffement climatique si les
tendances décrites par le giec se
produise sera encore là et touchera sera
touchée de plein fouet par ses
conséquences ou leurs enfants et les
générations qui décident aujourd'hui
bien ne seront plus là pour le constater
c'est à dire aujourd'hui les choix qui
sont faits sont guidés par des gens qui
vit dans l'instant t et c'est souvent le
problème du politique est guidé par le
temps court au détriment du temps long
d'ailleurs ça me concerne si l'industrie
était plutôt sûr du temps et donc ils
n'auront pas forcément assumer
directement les conséquences de ses
choix et qu'ils ne seront pas mis en
responsabilité pour
une action dans certains cas terminé on
va prendre encore deux trois minutes sur
sur la place de ces outils ces
entreprises de taille intermédiaire en
france vous aurez le mot de la
conclusion mais mathieu plane est ce que
sait pas ce qui nous différencie de
l'allemagne par exemple dans la capacité
de résistance à la crise depuis depuis
des années elle alors c'est clair enfin
jauger pâques ont longtemps mais le
mittelstand allemand effectivement
montre une capacité importante avec sont
issus de pays une balance excédentaire
qui est il fallait le 8 sept ou huit
points de pib c'est colossal
qui résistait malgré le mouvement d
industrialisation qu'on voit quand même
un peu partout dans le monde dans ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que la france
est caractérisé par sa c'est qu'on a un
tissu quand même de pme notamment de
start up qui est assez importants et de
grands groupes on a des multinationales
par contre elles produisent
effectivement à l'étranger alors parce
que aussi elle se rapproche des marchés
notamment locaux à l'étranger par contre
ce qu'on voit c'est que sur la balance
commerciale on est déficitaire sur les
biens produits devront produire en
france par contre on rapatrie les
dividendes les bénéfices que réalise ces
grands groupes étrangers dont vous avez
des rentrées de revenus par ces grands
groupes mais par contre elles produisent
beaucoup moins en france qui n'est pas
le cas de l'allemagne qui continue à
réaliser sa valeur ajoutée en tout cas
industriels en france or en allemagne
faye coirier pour pour conclure qu
est-ce qui qu'est ce qu'il faudrait pour
même si voilà laisser ces entreprises de
taille intermédiaire que vous
représentez on l'a compris vous ne
l'avez dit en début de débat elles ont
un poids économique important en france
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait dans là on est
en pleine campagne électorale qui
démarre pour booster encore ce secteur
alors juste pour dire elles ont très
bien résisté à la crise un voleur est
dit très peu de recul et elles ont très
vite à réaccélérer puisqu'on est sur 42
pour son investissement en plus en 2021
que sur 2010 9 27% de création d'emplois
en plus qu'en 2019 qui était pas une
mauvaise année donc c'est des boîtes qui
ont un vrai potentiel de rebond très
rapide elles sont très plastique qui
sont peu agile que plus agile et elles
sont engagées puisque 75% des de ces
boîtes ce n'est quand même d
actionnariat engagé de long terme
familiaux privé 80% des établissements
province il ya un enjeu territorial
important qu'est ce que nos territoires
sont très très on le sait avec des
situations variables qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait moi je pense que c'est nous les
toners il faut regarder la moyenne
européenne est ici on est si on met nos
entreprises armes égales avec leurs
leurs principales concurrentes
européennes puisque l'europe est notre
marché domestique une telle issa exporte
ça se développe et ses impôts de
production charge et réglementation
parce que la simplification on en a
vraiment vraiment besoin on a une
lourdeur qui nous coûte très très cher
c'est pas du coup identifié mais ça nous
coûte très cher en temps en énergie en
projet qui ne se font pas si on
travaille sept succès ces trois sujets
franchement je crois très très fortement
une capacité dans les cinq à dix ans qui
viennent à la france en tout cas
peut-être pas rattraper l'allemagne on
va pas remonter de 5500 à 12000 mais
espérons repasser à 7 8 9 milles si
c'est le cas ce sera le plein emploi et
on aura une économie française beaucoup
plus costaud beaucoup plus résiliente
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat à venir dans sens
public le regard de vos lieux de
violence dans les stades de foot
français une série d'incidents de
bagarres d'envahissement de terrain qui
ont marqué le retour du public après une
saison blanche pour cause de qu'ovide
peut-on en finir avec le hooliganisme
faut-il durcir la loi alors que six
grands textes ont déjà été votées en 30
ans réponse dans une petite dizaine de
minutes mais d'abord notre reportage au
coeur des territoires les électeurs ont
la parole